they're our first speaker against the
motion identity politics is tearing
society apart is Dawn foster dawn please
take to the podium Guardian columnist
who writes on politics Social Affairs
and economics and also a staff writer
for Jacobin magazine dawn
[Applause]
so as some of you might have noticed I
am a woman
I'm white I have a disability and when I
think about politics and when I talk
about politics a lot of those identities
to come into it
so when I think about austerity I look
at how austerity affects certain groups
more than others so in particular
austerity affects women 82% of all cuts
the government have made a impact women
if you look at the if you look at the
pay gap for instance women are paid less
than men but if you narrow it down black
women are paid a lot less than than
other than other people so when you
think about politics identity does have
to come into it because everybody
experiences things differently you know
personally but also in terms of
economics in terms of you know how it
affects community etc I'm going to think
about the people well when I come across
the people who complain about this it
always seems to be elusive ly boomers
sorry I am closer in age to Kyle's
daughter than Kemal so I am I am of the
generation that is part partly
interested in identity politics I don't
think it could deflate things I think
you know people live their life in a
normal way and obviously your identity
is part of that so everything that
affects you everything that makes see
makes up it makes up the person that is
you including your likes your hobbies or
dislikes etc it all comes together to
form a whole person and I don't think
that you know talking to people and
understanding that people have different
views different experiences of life you
know because of different identities I
don't think it actually like deflates
things I don't think it puts people in a
box I think it allows us be more
expansive with policy I think he allows
us to look at political policy and think
about how different groups will be
affected by it
and that you know and therefore stop
discrimination within that kind of thing
there's a lot there was a huge amount of
concern about universities about people
being no platformed about people not
being allowed to speak etcetera and I
always find it really fascinating that
so many people get upset by a small
number of students in the Student Union
when almost nobody else will have heard
of these little these small societies
these small groups and I think it's I
think the big problem is that we have
older people who have you know columns
in big magazines huge access of media
constantly say that they are being
silenced I know this because they write
constantly that they are being silenced
they go on TV to talk about the fact
that they have been silenced
and you know I think if they were I
wouldn't be constantly hearing about
them and I think you know I think
actually I don't see politics helps
those people because it allows them to
constantly place articles in the
spectator in spiked magazine in all
sorts of places talking about the fact
that they have been silenced and that
identity politics is ruining their life
etc and you know think about Lionel
speech I have a lot of friends who are
white men and I don't look at them and
say good lord you're so privileged it's
disgusting because they are my friends
and I don't think of people you know in
small I don't put people in small boxes
I don't look at them as a you know
having a tick box on their chest that
explains things about them I think that
you know for instance me having having
disability changes my life somewhat I'm
in hospital a lot my friends know that
and come and see me but it doesn't
really change anything else I might need
some things like for instance if we
decide to have strobe light in here
I wouldn't be able to sit and sage but
that's about it
don't do that
and I find it really really fascinating
that the big panic comes from older
people a very small number of older
people who you know who as Lionel was
saying that the people who are into
politics are relatively wealthy tend to
be wise etc but whenever I read articles
about people being silent so that people
being kicked out by the empty politics
it's always homeowners in their 50s it's
always people who are relatively
comfortable haven't lived through the
you know the global financial crash
didn't really affect them it seems you
know it seemed such an obsession with
with those people I've met people who
were absolutely desperate to get removed
from panels just because they wanted to
talk about the backlash that came with
it and they knew that if they were
removed from a small panel in Student
Union they could make a huge amount of
money talking about it you know going on
the BBC talking about how they were
silenced writing as a spectator about
how they were silenced and absolutely
nobody at any point thinking why because
they aren't clearly this person's being
punished everybody I think that empty
politics is actually really really
helpful in terms of making sure that we
think more deeply about how policy
affects people about how we can stop
kind of get you know gaps in admission
so University how we can stop people
being paid less how we can look at the
fact that if you are disabled you are
less likely to get a job and how we can
you know change things to bring other
people in and I think that I think that
we have to move past the you know
terrifying fear that a lot of boomers
have around this you know people when I
look at my friends I don't you know that
have tick-box in my head that appears
like you know like some kind of sci-fi
thing that breaks down what they are and
who they are we might have conversations
about
kind of you know what so I'm stationed
with my friend the other day about the
fact that they had been the victim of a
homophobic attack but identity doesn't
always come up and sometimes it does and
it's very I think it's a lot more useful
to talk about it and think about how
discrimination happens and how we can
stop that from happening one one really
really key bit I think your David will
talk about this is University Admissions
so for instance Oxford you know had a
huge race problem they have a huge class
problem and you know bringing that up
and talking about it means that they
will actually take some some action and
think about that there have been some
court cases where people have looked at
the fact that that you know certain
policies are bound to affect women
therefore they are discriminatory other
policies for instance like exclusively
seem to hit disabled people and those
people have gone to court and talked
about the fact they've been
discriminated against and often one of
the cases and change the policy so I
think that you know if we want to have a
more equal society there is no way we
can do that without thinking about
identity without thinking about how
certain things mean that other people
find it harder to get into certain jobs
find it harder to reach certain things
or even you know come into a building
because there isn't a wheelchair ramp so
I think that you know identity politics
is not about deciding who who is the
villain who is the most privileged who
we should you know never ever talk about
and attack and we talk about their
privilege I think it's much more about
making sure that our society is more
welcoming to people and that political
policy doesn't discriminate against
individuals and big groups
it doesn't Roman austerity massively
affects women and it massively you know
if you are a woman and you are disabled
you're doubly discriminated against by
certain policies that is identity
politics and you know I think we need to
remember that if we are making policy it
needs to be more
well it needs to make sure that for
instance if you are a young black person
and you're applying for a certain job
you know or a place in the university
you aren't discriminated against by the
way that the interview takes place and
so I think as empty politics is about
equality it's about making sure that
everybody has the same access and that
access might be slightly different based
on their identity and I think that it's
led to a lot of people thinking more
deeply about how they act and how
society should be built so I am against
the motion I think that we should be
more equal and I think the identity
politics is key to that we can't move
past identity we can't ignore identity
and I think that you know maybe at some
point the boomers will understand that
[Applause]